nouvelle mission navale pour le en libye
les chefs de la diplomatie européenne
sont parvenus hier à un accord pour
déployer des navires de guerre l'est de
la libye objectif empêcher les
livraisons d'armes à ce pays
à condition de ne pas laisser cette
opération encourager les traversées de
migrants florian lambert un accord
commun pour lancer une nouvelle mission
navale en libye l'union européenne est
parvenue ce lundi un accord pour
déployer des navires de guerre à l'est
de la libye un accord inattendu dont se
félicite le chef de la diplomatie
européenne
josette borel nous avons convenu de
lancer une nouvelle opération en
méditerranée et l'opération sofia sera
fermée l'opération sofia toucher à sa
fin le 20 mars et ce jour-là l'opération
sofia se terminera mais nous allons
lancer une nouvelle opération en
méditerranée et nous avons convenu que
cette opération aura pour objectif la
mise en oeuvre de l'embargo sur les
armes imposé par le conseil de sécurité
des nations unies une opération initiée
en 2015 et qui a pour but de contrôler
les flux migratoires et les causes des
trafics humains en méditerranée autre
volet de l'opération sofia
l'entraînement des garde côtes libyens
depuis l'été 2010 8
ils sont chargés par l'europe de
coordonner les sauvetages de réfugiés
une mission que la libye en guerre était
incapable de mener à bien
selon les ong le commandant veux
préciser qu'il y a eu 90 morts lorsque
nous étions au large près de la côte de
garat bulli à l'est de tripoli en libye
et qu'il n'y avait pas de bateau pour
les sauver parmi les réticents l'italie
ou encore l'autriche qui voyaient dans
l'opération sofia un billet d'entrée en
europe pour des milliers de migrants
clandestins des navires de guerre seront
envoyés fin mars dans les eaux à l'est
de la libye si ces livraisons permettent
le transport est légal de migrants
l'accord entre les états membres sera
rompu